what we're going to do in this video is
start talking about forces that exist
between even neutral atoms or neutral
molecules and the first of these
intermolecular forces we will talk about
are london dispersion forces so it
sounds very fancy but it's actually a
pretty interesting and almost intuitive
phenomenon
so we are used to thinking about atoms
unless they say we have a neutral atom
so it has the same number of protons and
electrons and so that's all those are
all the protons and the and the neutrons
in the nucleus and then it'll have a
cloud of electrons so i'm just imagining
all these electrons kind of jumping
around that's how i'm going to represent
it and let's imagine and this is
definitely not drawn to scale the
nucleus would actually be much smaller
if it was but let's say that there is an
adjacent atom right over here and it's
also neutral maybe it's the same type of
atom it could be different but we're
going to say it's neutral
and it also has an electron crowd cloud
and so if these are both
neutral in charge how would they be
attracted to each other and that's what
london dispersion forces act to explain
because we have observed that even
neutral atoms and neutral molecules can
get attracted to each other and the way
to think about it is
electrons are constantly jumping around
probabilistically they're in this
probability density cloud where electron
could be anywhere at any given moment
but they're not always going to be
evenly distributed you can imagine that
there is a moment where that left atom
might look like this just for a moment
where most of or maybe slightly more of
the electrons are spending time on the
left side
of the atom then on the right side so
maybe it looks something like that
and so for that brief moment you have a
partial negative charge this is the
greek letter delta lower case delta
which is
used to denote partial charge and on
this side
you might have a partial positive charge
because remember when it was evenly
distributed the negative charge was
offset by the positive charge of the
nucleus but here on the right side
because there's fewer electrons here
maybe you have a partial positive on the
left side you have where most of the
electrons are in that moment partial
negative
now what might this induce
in the neighboring atom think about that
pause the video think about what might
happen in the neighboring atom then
well we know that like charges repel
each other and opposite charges attract
each other so if we have a partial
positive charge out here on the right
side of this left atom well then the
negative electrons might be attracted to
it in this right atom
so these electrons here might actually
be pulled a little bit to the left
so they might be pulled a little bit to
the left
and so that will
induce what is called a dipole
so now you'll have a partial negative
charge on the left side of this atom and
then a partial
positive charge on the right side of it
and we already had a randomly occurring
dipole on the left sand side but then
that would have induced a dipole on the
right hand side a dipole is just when
you have the separation of charge where
you have your positive negative charges
at two different parts of a molecule or
an atom or really anything
but in this world then all of a sudden
these two characters are going to be
attracted to each other or the atoms are
going to be attracted to each other and
this attraction that happens due to
induced dipoles that is exactly what
london dispersion forces is all about
you can actually call london dispersion
forces as induced dipole-induced dipole
forces there they become attracted to
each other because of what could start
out as a temporary imbalance of
electrons but then it induces a dipole
in the other atom or the other molecule
and then they get attracted so the next
question you might ask is how strong can
these forces get and that's all about a
notion of polarizability
how easy is it to polarize an atom or
molecule
and generally speaking the more
electrons you have so the larger the
electron cloud
larger
electron cloud
electron cloud
which is usually associated with molar
mass
so usually molar mass
then the higher polarizability you're
going to have because you're going to
have more electrons to play around with
if this was a helium atom which has a
relatively small electron cloud you
couldn't have a significant imbalance at
most you might have two electrons on one
side which would cause some imbalance
but on the other hand imagine a much
larger atom or a much larger molecule
you could have much more significant
imbalances three four five fifty
electrons and that would create a
stronger temporary dipole which would
then induce a stronger dipole in the
neighbors that could domino through the
entire sample of that molecule so for
example if you were to compare
some noble gases to each other and so we
can look at the noble gases here on the
right hand side if you were to compare
the london dispersion forces between say
helium and argon which one would you
think would have higher london
dispersion forces a bunch of helium
atoms next to each other are a bunch of
argon atoms next to each other
well the argon atoms have a larger
electron cloud so they have higher
polarizability
and so you're going to have higher
london dispersion forces and you can
actually see that in their boiling
points for example the boiling point of
helium
is
quite low
it is negative
268.9 degrees celsius
while the boiling point of argon it's
still at a low temperature by our
standards but it's a much higher
temperature than the boiling point for
helium it's at negative 185.8
degrees celsius
so one way to think about this if you
were at say negative
270 degrees celsius you would find a
sample of helium in a liquid state but
as you warm things up as you get beyond
negative
268.9 degrees celsius you're going to
see that those london dispersion forces
that are keeping those helium atoms
together sliding past each other in a
liquid state they're going to be
overcome
by the energy due to the temperature and
so they're going to be able to break
free of each other and essentially the
helium is going to boil and you're going
to enter into a gaseous state the state
that most of us are used to seeing
helium in but that doesn't happen for
argon until a good bit warmer still cold
by our standards and that's because it
takes more energy to overcome the london
dispersion forces of argon because the
argonne atoms have larger electron
clouds
so generally speaking the larger the
molecule because it has a larger
electron cloud it'll have higher
polarizability and higher london
dispersion forces but also the shape of
the molecule matters the more that the
molecules can come in contact with each
other the more surface area they have
exposed to each other the more likely
that they can induce these dipoles in
each other for example butane can come
in two different forms it can come in
what's known as n-butane which looks
like this
so you have four carbons and ten
hydrogens
so two
three
10. this is known as n
butane but another form of butane known
as isobutane would look like this so you
have three carbons in the main chain and
then you have one carbon that breaks off
of that middle carbon and then they're
all
they all have four
bonds and the leftover bonds you could
say are with the hydrogens
so it would look
like this
this right over here is isobutane
isobutane
now if you had a sample of a bunch of
n-butane versus a sample of a bunch of
isobutane which of these you think will
have a higher boiling point pause this
video and think about that
well if you have a bunch of n-butanes
next to each other imagine another
n-butane
right over here
it's going to have more surface area to
its neighboring butanes because it is a
long molecule it can expose that surface
area to its neighbors
while the isobutane in some ways is a
little bit more compact it has lower
surface here it doesn't have these big
long chains and so because you have
these longer n-butane molecules you're
going to have higher london dispersion
forces they obviously have the same
number of atoms in them they have the
same number of electrons in them so they
have similar size electron clouds they
have the same molar mass but because of
n-butane's elongated shape they're able
to get closer to each other and induce
more of these dipoles so just by looking
at the shape of n-butane versus
isobutane you say higher london
dispersion forces in n-butane so it's
going to have a higher boiling point
it's going to require more energy to to
overcome the london dispersion forces
and get into a gaseous state